uh what did jeb actually tell you when
you finally got the rolls you find out
who you're playing did he like pull back
the curtain on like everything that
might happen because the thing about
vikings is
any character could get killed at any
time oh absolutely well jeb has a jedi
very generous with
what he's thinking and the possibilities
moving forward i mean he would talk at
great lengths about everything we could
do everything we're gonna do everything
we're not gonna do you know because we
are changing some things and you know
pulling things
together and apart from historical facts
but
but yeah i mean uh
he uh he really he really right off the
bat really laid it all out on the table
for us and then try you know got us
involved in the in the making of the
whole story arc with the characters
absolutely i remember um
[Music]
one of the was one of the first days
over on set and uh
jeb took me around and revealed with the
the makeup and the hair and the costume
team the look that they were going for
for canute and you can just imagine
uh
to be told that i was going to be given
that full
full viking treatment with you know
the shaved head and the beard and the
and the amazing armor and
the tattoos that you will you'll see
more of as the series progresses uh
just very excited yeah
how much like those costumes are so cool
how much did you really want to leave
set wearing everything with the hair and
everything just go to a local
supermarket and be like hey
well i'm not sure i would pay a lot of
attention but
bradley probably would
you know what the
the the costumes are just phenomenal
you're right i would love to have those
costumes in my wardrobe i would have i
should have stolen some
there's always next season assuming
you've
survived exactly
one of the things though that's pretty
crazy about the show is the scale and
scope of some of the action and like the
world building especially like that
london bridge sequence it's out of
control um what was your for both of you
what was your reaction when you're
reading these scripts and seeing what
like jeb wants to do in terms of the
scale
well that is a big one yeah episode four
i mean reading that i was completely
glued to the page like how are they
gonna do this are we actually gonna film
this and it felt like a season finale
but it's only halfway through
and it just kicks off even further from
there so i mean that was a treat but but
filming the whole thing was
there's a lot of moving parts and
and
but you know it took a long time but
then seeing it on the screen is so
rewarding and i i absolutely enjoy it
yeah jeb was teasing us from a very
early stage about f4 on the bridge
and saying that he'd been out to recce
this and he'd been out to wrecking that
and he'd seen parts of the set because
um that whole set that was uh filmed
over four separate locations it was
built in four separate locations and so
he kept teasing us you wait you wait you
could you're not going to believe these
sets when you get to see them and he was
building it up and building it up
building it up and man they you really
didn't disappoint because when we turned
up when we had one day i remember we had
about 250 extras we had maybe 15 20
horses on set and uh
you know five or six cameras rolling it
the the the scale of it was just
unbelievable and um yeah
it's
it just looks so epic it's it's so
filmic it's so cinematic you know it's
incredible to think that it's that it's
tv
in this day and age it's it's remarkable
for both of you what is it like actually
acting when you have so many people on
set with you watching and you're like
the focal point and there's all these
people standing there is it cool is it a
little bit nerve-wracking knowing [ __ ] i
really gotta make this take well i mean
that's what we always do uh if anything
that should be our comfort zone you know
so uh yeah that didn't feel
nerve-wracking to me because yeah like i
said that's that's what we usually do if
you're well prepared
you're okay that's a very good point as
long as you if you've done your homework
then you can sit back and you can enjoy
it somewhat you know but uh
the real real nerves come and you can
see it in people's eyes when they
haven't done their homework then then
you can be in real trouble because
there's a lot of eyes
on you
one of the things about this is that
normally i'm talking to people and i say
oh i love season one i can't i hope you
guys get to make a season two you've
already filmed season two
which is amazing i love it so um
obviously a lot of people are gonna
watch the first eight episodes in a day
and they're gonna wonder what's next so
can you tease anything about season two
well i can promise you it's going to be
a forward and upwards trajectory story
wise
i mean again getting the scripts you
think i mean i don't i don't have
imagination for what they're writing so
i'm continually amazed every time i get
the new scripts
and seeing season two uh i mean i was
just i was ecstatic it's
it's so good
so i can promise you more that's what i
can promise you yeah and like vikings do
not take a backwards step
they do not i love learning about the
behind the scenes for the making of a
show so for soon to be fans is there
anything you think that might surprise
them to learn about the actual making of
vikings valhalla well maybe
like this big set piece in episode four
you might be surprised to know that i
never saw the bridge at all until i saw
it on tv because all of my bits on the
boat were filmed on a lake with with
nothing in front of us
and i know the bridge was in four pieces
and bradley you never saw us on the
boats
no we um we filmed the majority of of
the actual bridge
in the field or on the backlots so and
the bits taking place under the bridge
that's also on different locations
so the composition it looks seamless but
you might be surprised at just how
dispersed it really is
to the extent where i've never even seen
the bridge with my own eyes it looks so
good um i already got to stop i'm just
going to say congratulations on the show
i wish you guys nothing but the best and
i hope i get to talk to you for season
two and three and beyond
thank you steve thank you so much
you